el 3 de octubre de 2022 en medio de
manila la vida de esta familia cambió
para siempre
aquí fue exactamente donde asesinaron a
Percy él iba conduciendo y una moto con
dos asesinos lo adelantó por la
izquierda le dispararon tres veces
en estos videos grabados desde la cámara
del vehículo de la víctima se ve a los
asesinos en moto dar media vuelta e irse
el presunto autor del crimen fue
arrestado Percy lapiz era un periodista
y locutor de radio conocido por criticar
los abusos del gobierno en sus programas
para mí es difícil salir y conducir por
la calle Cuando veo una moto me da miedo
que sea un asesino
los seis hijos y la esposa de Percy
lapid obtuvieron protección policial
pero es intermitente el hermano de Percy
que también es periodista se ha
encargado de mantener la presión
política y mediática para que la
investigación continúe
Este es el logo del programa original de
Percy se llamaba las llamas de Percy
está la idea del fuego porque él
denunciaba todos los temas de injusticia
y corrupción en Filipinas
solía criticar a los presidentes sobre
todo a duterte durante seis años el
controvertido presidente filipino
Rodrigo duterte impuso una cultura del
asesinato público incitando a la policía
o a los asesinos a sueldo a acabar con
Los Traficantes de droga y los
consumidores pero también con las voces
disidentes en particular las de
activistas de derechos humanos o algunos
periodistas
cree que el expresidente podría estar
detrás del asesinato de su hermano
es muy probable una vez dijo que los
periodistas no estaban exentos de los
asesinatos
Escuchar al presidente del país decir
eso nos hizo temblar
a pesar de los riesgos Roy ha decidido
continuar con la emisión de radio de su
hermano para que las llamas de Percy
lapid no se extingan
actualmente filipinas tiene un nuevo
presidente Ferdinand Marcos Junior que
dice querer respetar los Derechos
Humanos Pero hay un aspecto en el que
duterte y Marcos convergen la lucha
contra el comunismo en 2020 una ley
antiterrorista le concedió amplios
poderes a las autoridades para que
detuvieran a cualquier persona designada
como terrorista y para muchos miembros
del gobierno Eso incluye algunos
activistas y políticos de extrema
izquierda
somos Víctimas de noticias falsas
aquí dice
No se deje engañar por esos terroristas
y aparece en mi foto y mi nombre
es lo mismo que hacía el senador
mccarthy en Estados Unidos Durante los
años 50 y 60 en esa época se llamaba la
casa de brujas comunistas
en realidad lo que dicen Es que todas
esas voces disidentes pertenecen a la
izquierda insurgente y que entonces son
criminales incluso aunque uno sea
activista Sin armas se convierte en un
blanco y puede ser asesinado
ser marxista no es un crimen
Pero según el gobierno el partido
comunista filipino no ha renunciado a la
lucha armada secretamente estaría
financiando el nuevo ejército del pueblo
brazo armado del partido esta
insurrección maoísta no es una novedad
desde hace casi medio siglo el
movimiento ha tratado de derrocar al
gobierno mediante las armas y afirma que
su objetivo es darle el poder al pueblo
el ejército está integrado por unos 2000
soldados entre los que hay hombres y
mujeres operan el campo y busca reclutas
en las universidades la hija de esta
peluquera se unió al movimiento en 2019
y cortó por completo El vínculo con su
madre
como madre es muy duro ver que mi hija
haya sido reclutada usada por esa
organización por esos políticos
no sé qué va a pasar con ella
quiero que otros padres Víctimas de este
reclutamiento
vean que deben luchar para que sus hijos
tengan una oportunidad de escapar
y volver a la sociedad
Pero por qué los llama terroristas
porque matan gente si bien la rebelión
es una realidad las leyes
antiterroristas actuales han
incrementado los arrestos y asesinatos
de activistas esa es una de las
reivindicaciones de estos manifestantes
que salieron a las calles para
conmemorar el aniversario de una de las
figuras de la independencia filipina
Ah carapatán
este es mi padre fue asesinado en 2020
fue víctima de una ejecución
extrajudicial cometida por la
administración duterte y desde entonces
no se ha hecho justicia su padre llori
porque era un activista de izquierda que
organizaba distribuciones de alimentos
durante la pandemia pero los servicios
de inteligencia lo acusaron de ser un
Rebelde maoísta
el asesinato de Mi padre es un símbolo
de la impunidad y de la ausencia de
Justicia que impera aquí en Filipinas
filipinas
el gobierno quería silenciar a los
activistas y las voces disidentes y su
manera de proceder es asesinarlos
en septiembre de 2022 la justicia salió
en defensa de la extrema izquierda y
declaró que el partido comunista no
podía ser calificado como terrorista por
las autoridades pero los asesinatos
continúan y las familias siguen
sufriendo en tres años alrededor de 30
activistas y periodistas han sido
asesinados en el país